[Music]
good scene everyone let's have fun with
this one best scene in the movie
is it bad if i start the single like
this
[Music]
we'll get on set edits and we will all
of a sudden see paul rudd do some
hilarious improv oh
i don't have a watch and instead of the
people
off camera pulling their hair out
they're pulling their pens out and
they're getting excited
i like weird jokes by the way as does
marvel as does kevin feige
and steven broussard they're all comedy
lovers all right here we go picture
you'd be shocked at how many insane
ideas you can go to them with and
they're like oh yeah okay that's cool
because these are not small movies so to
be able to approach it in that way where
you're really trying some way outside of
the box
things that's fun maybe you just need
someone watching your back
like a partner there are a lot of things
that excite me about ant-man and the
wasp but
i think the biggest is to see wasp
herself to see hope van dyne as a fully
formed hero in this movie
the first and foremost primary
motivation and reason to play hope again
was to put on that suit
she so desperately wanted to follow in
the footsteps of her
parents who had been incredible
superheroes in their day and in her
formative years
so she's finally doing that pleasure
doing business with you sonny
you could see in that first film that
she was frankly more capable than scott
lang was of being a superhero
and her father because of the loss of
her mother emotionally didn't want her
to do this
and now we get to see her with the
gloves off and becoming a superhero
the film not by accident isn't called
ant-man too it's called ant-man and the
wasp
and it's really the story of these
characters coming to their own as a team
follow my lead
i loved that she's such a seminal
character in the marvel comic book world
and that she was one of the founding
members of the avengers
i would have lots of conversations with
peyton that janet was
a warrior and she is a very important
and brilliant scientist
unto herself which was exciting to me i
told
marvel four years ago if you
ever bring a janet van dyne into one of
these films
please make it michelle pfeiffer i
really want michelle pfeiffer to play my
mom not only is she
the most beautiful woman to have ever
walked planet earth
she was also so cool and i somehow wound
up with
michelle pfeiffer and michael douglas
playing my parents and both being
equally
incredible and talented let's go see our
daughter
there's just a fun factor to it i got
this whole new generation
of people under 15 years old and they
say hey hank pym
and crash
i loved at this phase let's say in my
life
that i'm playing a superhero the message
that it sends to
women of all ages that we are still
kicking ass come on
the wasp costume that you saw at the end
of the first film
was an old prototype from the 1980s
so it looks totally different mother
never got to use it
and now i realized that they were
working on it for you
because technology has evolved i updated
the suit with my father we made a new
one based on the prototype
that fit hope's needs for this day and
age it's about damn time
this is one of evangeline's costumes
trying to find this color took
a very very long time because somebody
at marvel
jokingly said this is a combination of
gold and silver
and they decided to say that it was
gilbert so what we've got here
is we've got a reflective silver in the
background and then we've got a patent
leather gold which is cut with a
honeycomb
on two different levels just to try and
get this elusive gilva color
this piece here just the stomach are
there there are over 90 pieces just in
that
because it needs to move it needs to be
flexible we don't want it to
restrict evangeline
there's so much we didn't know about
this place henry world upon worlds
entire civilizations
far more than we ever theorized
[Music]
it's okay
passing through we stake no claim
[Music]
[Music]
from the very beginning we knew there
was going to be a come out moment for
wasp that was going to be her real kind
of
this is my character this is who i am
and it's going to be the restaurant
sequence
the stunt team have four to five weeks
of pretty intensive training so when
evangeline would turn up before filming
we have a really great idea of exactly
what we need to do
that's been great in terms of figuring
out how she moves how she fights how she
flies
seeing these two fight in tandem
together like how do they
coordinate their power sets peyton had
mentioned a few things that he really
liked and then evangeline would come in
and then we would kind of tweak it for
how she would see her character moving
i was asking to build a lot of these s
curves into her fight style i think for
me that's just a suggestion of fluidity
and grace
and when she fights i feel like she
should look effortless it's just
something she was born to do
she seems more intense we're gonna have
a lot of fun today we're gonna be out
here for three four hours hopefully
we're gonna see some humpbacks right
get some humpback whales they're
thinking what is this the latest dance
craze the home back i don't know how it
would go what would what would it even
be
i'm personally a whale head i freak for
whales i love them ever since i was a
kid
i'm not trained really in biology or
knowing anything about them
i've memorized a couple of facts but i
couldn't go deep this is not a whale
learning cruise it's a whale watching
cruise
oh wait well hold on now looks like
looks like we might have some company
here folks
yep that's a breach oh look at that
could be moby mick that's uh
moby dick's irish cousin okay folks i
can say that i'm
irish dutch irish actually that's
that's not that's not a whale uh
okay folks don't panic please just uh
don't panic
don't pan don't panic jump jump jump
over boy
daniel gubler g-o-o-o b-l-e-r
g-o-o-o-b-l-e-y-e-r
g-o-o-o-b-y-l-e-y-e-r
hubler daniel but if you want i could
jump in your patrol car we can go out
and hunt this perp down
well we got to close the bridges down at
least don't you think
you know i was thinking about being a
cop myself but the hours don't make
sense
this better be good it was mine we
checked every security camera in the
area they all had ants on
ants no ants in this one though
exterminator sprayed the store two days
ago
what is that
[Music]
well that my friend is how i'm staying
in the picture now the taking that lab's
got to be worth billions
find them and who's mine i want to know
who that
is right
[Music]
talk about compact cars damn
should have paid those parking tickets
oh
no my sandwich was in there
well at least now i'll be able to park
in san francisco
oh man i just stole this car
thank god it's a rental well
looks like i'm walking oh geez all my
coupons were in there
talk about diminishing returns oh man
everything is shrinking on me well
the 60s were fun but now i'm paying for
it
so how long have you been ant-man again
not long it just sort of happened
i wish i could fight bad guys like you
seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
like a partner
[Music]
dr penn i actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when this crazy creepy ghost who
like walks through walls and stuff solar
tech
and now she wants to take over the world
or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn to us happy
because we robbed you do you remember
that's us
follow my lead
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low i'll go high i have wings why
would i go low
hey what'd i miss we were just tiny
i was partners with hank on a project
called goliath how big did you get
my record 21 feet you
65 feet 65.
if you two are finished comparing sizes
[Music]
65.
[Music]
you